estas imágenes satelitales confirman que
un convoy militar ruso se extiende a lo
largo de 60 kilómetros vehículos
blindados artillería caminos de
suministro se dirigen a la capital de
ucrania controlar kiev es el principal
objetivo del kremlin que aseguró que
mantendrá el asedio hasta alcanzar los
objetivos planeados por cual la disputen
anoche las tropas rusas bombardearon la
ciudad de nuevo obligando a la población
a refugiarse en los resguardos
subterráneos
anoche escuchamos las sirenas tres veces
pasamos el tiempo en los pasillos porque
ese es el lugar más seguro del
apartamento
también en hard coffee la segunda ciudad
de ucrania el bombardeo se intensifica
las zonas residenciales están siendo
atacadas según las autoridades locales
también hay civiles entre los muertos
harkov sigue bajo control ucraniano por
el momento en carson en el sureste del
país los rusos ya están a las puertas de
la ciudad según el alcalde el ejército
ha establecido puestos de control en
todos los puntos de entrada
por último en óptica en el noreste del
país las autoridades locales anunciaron
el martes la muerte de más de 70
soldados ucranianos víctimas del
bombardeo de su base militar que se
remonta al domingo